vous cherchez à joindre à mener tout
attribut
ya quelqu'un
abba
[Musique]
qui te fit
est morte si tu veux mon avis il a été
torturé je veux tu qu'ils cet endroit
tout de suite début tu connais pas cet
endroit c'est malsain
je rentrerai pas à la maison tant que je
n'aurai pas trouvé qui avait
ravagé m'aurait pas arrêtée à la place
de ceux que tu vas voir à toi je te
conseille de te tenir à l'écart des deux
projets auxquels frangin
ton père tu es mais à ce point là c'est
son amour pour toi qui l'a tuée
qu'est ce que tu fais avec 7 h
c'est mon père qui me l'a donnée
[Musique]
lâche ça tu veux
faut reconnaître que tu es un sacré
numéro tu sais ça je vais mettre les
choses au point en route il m'en
faudrait je prends pas l'argent du puits
qui va mourir pourtant dumont du nuage
edu menace de tuer tous les habitants
quand quelqu'un de méchant mer c'est une
bonne chose on est d'accord
j'entends coeur qui bat
j'ai besoin de connaître la vérité tu
comprends
qu'est ce que tu as fais mon bébé
[Musique]